unbowed unbent unbroken the words of
house Martell have promised to our
enemies and a challenge to our lovers
thousands of years ago the warrior queen
Nymeria crossed into Dorne from Essos
fleeing the Dragonlords of a Lydia after
she landed she burned her ships all
10,000 of them so no cowards could slink
home what a woman
Dornish in spirit before she ever was in
flesh she was lucky to land in Dorne
where powerful women are not locked away
in SEPs and the beds of old men my
ancestor more smart l saw her and
desired her and proved that where armies
fail it Tom may succeed wedding his
strength to hers his spear to her son
they subdued all his rivals together
after the tradition of her people house
Martell then ruled Dorne as princes not
Kings unless the eldest child was a
daughter for unlike the rest of Westeros
our loyalty isn't commanded by a [ __ ] we
follow a prince or a princess Martell
just the same and we always have some
people forget that Aegon Targaryen
crowned himself Lord of six kingdoms not
seven when his sister marched on Dorne
she found no mighty hosts drawn up
against her for her Dragon to burn in
her soldiers to slaughter the sands
swirled men died and her dragons saw
nothing the Sun shone men died and her
dragon bowed to our greater fire the
Targaryen retreated with their tails
tucked between their legs of course in
later years his descendants would try
again they run the first succeeded at
great cost and reigned in Dorne for a
few glorious months one night his
steward pulled down a sash by his bed to
summon his consorts instead the canopy
split open in a hundred red scorpions
fell on him
he was a Tyrell you would think he would
be used to getting stung within a
fortnight house Martell again ruled a
free door eventually after centuries of
course ship house Martell got into bed
with Italians
we took King they run the second and his
sister for our own before they could
take each other and six kingdoms became
seven even now I do not blame my
ancestors one look at those long silver
locks it is not every day a man gets to
ride a dragon but they soon learned that
you can't leap off a dragon at will my
sister Elia she married Prince Rhaegar
Targaryen and became the princess she
already was in Dorne
she walked among vipers and none would
bite her in King's Landing she found
herself surrounded by lions
when Robert Baratheon rebelled against
his rightful king his future
father-in-law Tywin Lannister ordered
his beast Gregor Clegane to rape and
murder my sister along with her helpless
children and men called the Lannisters
heroes now Lannisters sit on the Iron
Throne
surrounded by the blasted sorts of
Aegon's broken foes I wonder if they
remember as I do that none of those
swords are ours I wonder if they see as
I do my sister's red blood soaking into
the stones of their precious red cape
maybe they need reminding the lion may
be a mighty beast but pride always lifts
his gaze to the horizon never seen in
the grass the Viper